[Music]
tonight's Mega Millions jackpot you may
have heard of this is up to about three
hundred and sixty million dollars yeah
and I heard my stage crew pooled their
money to buy some Mega Millions tickets
a lot of people do that that work
together they pool their money and they
bide Mega Millions tickets well with a
360 million dollar jackpot I was just
kind of curious what the people on my
crew would do if they won that kind of
money I'm just curious about it so Paul
how about you what would you do if you
want that kind of money I'd probably buy
a nice big house a couple of boats spend
most of my time sailing and no
disrespect mr. O'Brien I probably quit
my job I don't blame you you know you
throw in 60 million dollars that how
about you Matt I probably buy a ranch
and my wife and I would raise horses and
no disrespect mr. O'Brien but I'd quit
this crappy job in a heartbeat okay well
no disrespect taken how about you Lori
well you know if we were the big money I
guess I I would want to get my parents a
nice house and then put away a good
trunk for my kids college education and
then of course I would quit this piece
of job so fast I mean no disrespect yeah
how about how about you Brian go screw
yourself
yep but what would you do with the money
I guess I'd buy a boat and seriously you
prick go straight to hell no disrespect
well how about you Andre let me guess
you'd quit this job and then you'd tell
me off I don't know mr. O'Brien I like
working here very much that's so nice to
hear thank you however I will use my
newfound wealth to make life for you a
living hell every single day you'll be
looking over your shoulder wondering
what's that crazy rich boom mic operator
got in store for me today
I will hire an army literally an army of
people to torment and harass you 24/7
O'Brien your life will become a waking
nightmare and you won't beg me to make
it stop
so make it all stop with a bullet to
your brain because you would rather die
they continue living with the constant
relentless specter of my vengeful wrath
[Applause]
any anything else you want to add no
disrespect
[Music]
you